you know that Sarah Palin's back in the
news yeah yeah it's being reported that
Sarah Palin was not invited to John
McCain's memorial service she wasn't
invited yet was reported in this month's
issue of Osnap magazine regularly good
news for the economy consumer spending
grew in August in America so you can be
happy about that
that's good news yeah the two most
popular purchased items are
antidepressants and Canadian passports
so you can't purchase a Canadian put
that joke doesn't even make sense maybe
they're counterfeit how was that helping
me right now
I was having more fun during the breast
exam well he's still there he's still
there I'll see you later
what's your name sir Anthony all right
Conan good to meet you too what's she
doing here it's come out that was weird
fast
it's come out that the restaurant chain
in and out has donated $25,000 to the
Republican Party yeah some people yeah
know what makes sense because in and out
is the perfect description of a career
in Trump's White House
at this year's London Fashion Week the
catwalk is gonna feature the first ever
robot supermodel they're gonna have a
robot supermodel unbelievable now robots
are taking food out of the mouths of
those who don't eat what come on that's
a pretty good one what the hell you look
at me out here and I'm yelling at him I
know listen when you don't laugh at a
bad one I let it go that one I thought
had some quality you know well you will
get scolded yeah I'm gonna follow them
out to the parking lot there yeah
boarded you're gonna love this one
I'm not asking I'm telling the the Board
of Directors at Papa John's said they do
not I repeat do not want Papa John back
cuz he's making the company look bad
look bad yeah also making the company
look bad their pizza
you
you